♪ ♪
>> Greg: OWED TO BE THIS DUMB.
>> WHEN YOU SEE ENTIRE MEDIA
COMPANIES EXIST TO TEAR DOWN
JOE BIDEN, IS THERE EQUIVALENT
TO THAT ON THE LEFT, TEARING
DOWN FROM?
>> THERE REALLY ISN’T.
WHAT I WOULD SAY, IT’S A DIET OF
THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION THAT A
LOT OF THESE VOTERS ARE GETTING.
>> Greg: WAIT, THERE’S NO
ANTI-TRUMP NETWORK?
EVEN CNN ADMITS NOBODY WATCHES
CNN.
EVEN IF YOU DESPISE TRUMP,
YOU’VE GOT TO ADMIT THIS
DECEPTION DARES YOU TO LAUGH IN
ITS FACE.
THERE ISN’T AN ANTI-TRUMP MEDIA
COMPANY?
THERE MIGHT BE TWO DOZEN WITH
CNN LEADING THE HAIR ON FIRE
PACKED.
THE ONLY REASON EVERY TRUMP BOOK
GOES TO NUMBER ONE IS BECAUSE IT
HAS TWO CABLE NETWORKS DOING ITS
P.R. WHICH EXPLAINS WHY TWO
RECENT MASSIVE SURVEY SAY MEDIA
IS OVERWHELMINGLY BIASED AND
CANNOT BE TRUSTED.
IF ONLY THEIR DELUSIONAL
THINKING WERE RELEGATED TO THE
SILLY WORLD OF POLITICS OR BRIAN
STELTER’S HEAD BUT IT’S NOT.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO DENY THIS
REALITY DENY A LOT OF FAR UGLIER
FACTS.
RISING MURDER RATES, SHOOTINGS,
LOOTING, PROPERTY DESTRUCTION,
TAX ON THE ELDERLY, KILLINGS BY
BY --
ATTACKS ON FREE SPEECH, RIOTS
DESCRIBED AS PEACEFUL PROTESTS
REMEMBER HOW THE MEDIA PRETENDED
TO FIND IN THE POLICE WITH A
REASONABLE ASK?
FOR THIS TO SUCCEED, THEY HAD TO
BURY REALITY, LIKE GALLUP
SURVEYS SHOWING THAT OVER 80% OF
BLACKS AND HISPANICS WHILE THE
SAME AMOUNT OR MORE POLICE.
FUNNY HOW THE WHITE ANCHORS
NEVER BRING THAT UP.
IN ORDER FOR A LEFT-WING VIEW OF
THE WORLD TO EXIST, YOU MUST
PRETEND NONE OF THAT OTHER BAD
STUFF EXISTS.
MEANING THE CONSEQUENCES OF
LEFT-WING ACTION A DEMOCRATIC
LEADER IN ACTION.
YOU CAN THINK A MEDIA AND THE
LEFT WORKING TOGETHER TO
PRESERVE THEIR POWER.
MEANWHILE BRIAN STELTER DENIES
THE REALITY OF JOE BIDEN’S
DECLINE.
>> THIS IS JOE BIDEN OUT THERE
ON A VIGOROUS BIKE RIDE.
NOT WEARING A HELMET BUT
DEFINITELY WEARING A MASK.
>> Greg:FOX’S NARRATIVE AND TALK
NARRATIVE FOR MONTHS HAS BEEN
THE JOE BIDEN IS FALLING APART.
THERE HE IS RIDING A BIKE, OUT
FOR A BIKE RIDE.
>> Greg: COOL.
SO IF YOU RIDE A BIKE, YOU CAN
BE PRESIDENT.
THAT’S GOOD NEWS FOR THESE
FELLOWS.
CHECK THEM OUT.
YOU KNOW, I’VE GOT MY MONEY ON
THE PUG.
HE HAS A SOUND FISCAL POLICY.
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: THANK YOU, DANA, FOR
THE COURTESY LAUGH.
I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST.
HOW COULD PEOPLE SAY THERE’S NO
ANTI-TRUMP NETWORKS.
THAT’S THE LITERAL DEFINITION OF
DENIAL.
>> Dana: I HOPE I WASN’T
DISRUPTING YOUR MONOLOGUE.
I WAS LAUGHING THROUGH THE
ENTIRE THING.
WHEN I SAW THE TOPIC FOR TODAY,
I THOUGHT IT’S LIKE BASICALLY
THEY JUST MAKE MATERIAL FOR YOU
FOR YOUR MONDAY MONOLOGUE.
THERE ARE ABSOLUTELY ENTIRE
NETWORKS DEVOTED AND THERE HAVE
BEEN FROM THE BEGINNING.
REALLY NOT UNTIL AFTER HE WON.
IF YOU REMEMBER SOME OF THEM
WERE HELPFUL TO HIM WHEN HE WAS
A CANDIDATE.
AND THEN THEY CHANGE THEIR TUNE.
THE OTHER THING IS IF THAT’S A
VIGOROUS BIKE RIDE, I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE THE
CANDIDATES HAVE TO GO ON 45
MINUTE INTERVALS AND THEN WE
WILL FIND OUT IF THEY HAVE
VIGOROUS BIKE RIDES.
>> Greg: I DID IT RIDE
YESTERDAY, 15 MINUTES, IT’S JUST
THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF TIME TO DO
TABATA.
WHENEVER ANYONE DESCRIBES ACTION
AS VIGOROUS, IT’S A DOG WHISTLE
FOR BEING OLD.
IT’S LIKE OH, LOOK HOW SPRY HE
IS.
HE WENT RIGHT UP THOSE STAIRS.
>> Dagen: LOOKED, TWO
SENTENCES TOGETHER.
HEAR, HEAR.
BRAVO.
JOE BIDEN.
I ALWAYS LEARNED IF YOU CAN’T
SAY SOMETHING NICE ABOUT
SOMEBODY OR AN ENTIRE NETWORK,
DON’T SAY ANYTHING AT ALL.
I WILL SIT HERE AND DO AN
AUDITION FOR CNN WITH A SNEER ON
MY FACE IN MY MOUTH AGAPE
BECAUSE THAT’S THE EQUIVALENT OF
WHAT YOU GET.
ARMCHAIR PSYCHOANALYSIS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR HOW MANY
YEARS?
IT’S NOT REALLY ARMCHAIR.
IT’S MORE LIKE SANDBOX WHILE
THEY ARE EATING, YOU KNOW, WHAT
THE CAT LEFT BEHIND IN THE SAND.
I GET NOTHING FROM THIS.
IT’S THE EQUIVALENT OF A TODDLER
EATING TOILET PAPER.
NOT YOU BUT THE OTHER GUY.
>> Greg: WE WOULD NOT ADVISE
THAT AT ALL.
LAWRENCE, WE ALL WORKING TV.
I ENVISIONED THAT THERE WERE
PEOPLE IN THE CONTROL ROOM OR
THE PRODUCERS AND DIRECTORS WERE
COOL BURST OUT LAUGHING WHEN
THEY HEAR SOMEBODY SAY SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
THEY GO, DON’T WORK AT CNN?
>> Lawrence: HONESTLY THE SAD
PART ABOUT IT IS I FEEL THEY
BELIEVE IT WHICH IS REALLY
TELLING.
BUT WE LAUGH AT THIS.
WHEN YOU’RE LOOKING AT THIS FROM
A LOGICAL STANDPOINT, THIS IS
HURTFUL TO THEIR CANDIDATE,
JOE BIDEN.
HE’S NOT PREPARED FOR DEBATES.
HE’S NOT PREPARED FOR REAL
QUESTIONS.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY WEEK WE
SPENT TIME BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
HAS DONE SOME BIG INTERVIEW.
WE HAVE TO PICK IT APART, AS WE
SHOULD, BECAUSE IT’S THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE’S RUNNING FOR REELECTION.
BUT WE NEVER HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT FOR
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE HE DOESN’T DO
THIS TYPE OF INTERVIEWS AND WHEN
HE DOES DO A LAYOUT INTERVIEW,
WE ALWAYS HAVE TO TALK ABOUT HIS
GAFFES AND HIS RESPONSE TO EVERY
TAU QUESTION IS COME ON, MAN.
THERE’S GOING TO COME A POINT
WHERE HE HAS TO BE ON THE DEBATE
STAGE.
HE’S NOT GOING TO BE READY FOR
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
HE HASN’T BEEN INTERVIEWED.
THOSE QUESTIONS SHOULD COME
BEFORE THE DEBATE STAGE AND HE
HASN’T BEEN ABLE TO ANSWER THOSE
AND I DON’T THINK HE’S GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ANSWER THEM ON THE
DEBATE STAGE EITHER.
>> Greg: DONNA, I SAVED THE
BEST FOR LAST.
IT SHOULDN’T JOE, A VERY OLD
WHITE MALE, IF HE WAS TRULY NOT
RACIST, STEP ASIDE AND ALLOW A
WOMAN OF COLOR TO BECOME
PRESIDENT?
BY NOT STEPPING ASIDE, ISN’T HE
REAFFIRMING THE SUBTLE RACISM
WE’VE SEEN THEM EXPRESS OVER THE
PAST YEAR WITH HIS COMMENTARY
ABOUT BLACKS?
>> Donna: YOU STARTED OUT THE
SEGMENT TALKING ABOUT THE MEDIA
AND BIASED MAN’S GOING TO TELL
YOU IF YOU LOOK AT THE LAST FIVE
YEARS, THERE’S BEEN INCREASED
POLARIZATION IN THE MEDIA JUST
LIKE IT IS IN POLITICS AND
CULTURE.
THE SECOND THING, LAWRENCE, HE
HAS DONE 100 INTERVIEWS.
WHILE THEY ARE NOT AT ALL
PERFECT, HE’S DONE 100 AND HE
PARTICIPATED IN AT LEAST 12
DEBATES THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
MAYBE HE DOESN’T ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS YOU LIKE TO HEAR THE
ANSWER BUT HE IS CAPABLE OF
HOLDING HIS OWN.
>> Lawrence: LIKE WHEN HE SAID
LAST WEEK THAT BLACK FOLKS
WEREN’T DIVERSE.
>> Donna: LAWRENCE, IF I
COMMENT ON EVERYTHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
>> Lawrence: WE DO.
>> Donna: YOU DON’T.
YOU WHITEWASH AN AIRBRUSH WITH
TRUMP SAYS EVERY DAY.
>> Lawrence: ACTUALLY I DON’T.
>> Donna: HERE’S THE POINT I
WANT TO MAKE.
WE ARE GOING TO GET TO SEE
JOE BIDEN AND DONALD TRUMP, TWO
MEN IN THEIR 70s.
BY THE WAY, I DON’T THINK 70 IS
OLD.
I KNOW SOME OF YOU DO.
I DO BELIEVE IF HE IS UP FOR THE
JOB AND HE CAN HANDLE A JOB,
LIKE PRESIDENT REAGAN WAS ABLE
TO HANDLE THE JOB IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND LET’S
DEBATE THE MERITS OF THEIR
PROPOSALS AND THEIR ISSUES.
>> Lawrence: THIS IS WHY BIDEN
ISN’T READY.
EVERY SINGLE TIME WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT BIDEN, HIS
SURROGATES AND PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT HIM GO TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE’S GOT TO BE ABLE TO DEFEND
WHAT IS IDEOLOGY IS.
>> Donna: LAWRENCE, HAVE ME ON
YOUR SHOW AND I CAN BRING IT
DOWN SO WELL.
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT JOE BIDEN
AND HIS RACISM, I CAN TELL YOU
ABOUT TRUMP AND HIS RACISM.
IT HAS WHITE SUPREMACY WE ARE